[Applaudissements]
blatter dont je parle et aidant ils
s'attendent l'on mène ses instrus ouais
c'est ça nous on fait donc toutes les
femmes nous disent moss nous prenons
isabelle morini-bosc vous y est ce que
c'est vrai a dit là et dès que vous avez
rencontré dsk et qu'il a succombé à
votre charme
il n'a pas succombé hier en chambre
puisqu'il but in touski multinet tout ce
qui passait pour est attiré par tous y
compris les boutons de porz il s'agitait
un peu
[Applaudissements]
comment s'est passé a raconté moussa a
été et est extrêmement furtif c'est dire
qu'on a une soirée il était placé à côté
de moi et qu'il était ainsi fait que
comme le serpent qui se mord la queue
elle pouvait pas ne pas palper touchés
et héros monde bancal mais aussi envers
nationale était obligé mais
effectivement de faire ça pour pour pour
vous retirer si alors et vous à mai mais
bon ça c'est rien mais il faudrait
vraiment proposer quelque chose moi il
m'a pas dit tu veux chambre temps ah oui
oui mais il a proposé dix fois à d
autres jeunes femmes dans la même soirée
je les fais face à une maquilleuse de
france 3 où il a fait semblant d'avoir
oublié son fils au fax dans la loge ce
n'était pas de la grande motte vos
filofax alors pour les jeunes qui vous
regardent le filofax l'agenda ouais
c'est un agenda voilà c'est aussi le il
a appelé le lendemain en disant je veux
récupérer j'ai besoin de me joindre
cette jeune femme qui a sûrement dû me
mettre mon agenda de côté il l'avait vu
venir tout ça sans lui à france 3 il
veut mais on va vous le retrouvez votre
agenda monsieur strauss kahn non je veux
je veux pas moi je suis un socialiste je
veux embêter personne je vais m'en
occuper moi même et puis finalement
quand il a compris que en lançant il
aurait pas gain de cause il a raccroché
mais fut rima et c'était moi je n'ai vu
à airtel finalement ils ont retrouvé cet
agenda
ça m'intéresse alors pas du tout